and contrary to popular to belief  never been an escort for a Senator Ted  Cruz but  I'll tell you tonight it is the coolest  thing I've ever heard about Ted Cruz can  satanic possession be cured  well if you remove the possessor I guess  so yeah how is that done though well  biblically it would be through an  exorcism or something of that nature wow  that sounds extremely serious  well are you demonically possessed do  you agree with this book that is being  taught with kids that the babies are  racist  senator  not only do we have the DC jail which is  the DC Gulag but now we have Nancy  Pelosi's gazpacho police spying on  members of Congress they want to know  when you're eating they want to know if  you're eating a cheeseburger which is  very bad because Bill Gates wants you to  eat his fake meat that grows in a peach  tree dish